location okay thank you so it's another
talk on matrix multiplication
and we are studying uh the same things i
will first
give an overview of the results before
going through details
so we are studying the same thing as in
other thoughts so the exponent of matrix
multiplication
and we want to uh more precisely to
study upper bounds on this omega the
exponent of matrix multiplication so
this is another table describing the
main improvements on the exponent of
square matrix multiplication
and uh today's talk with this talk will
be about
this uh slight improvement over the
result by the nervous scale right let's
go with
and so uh all this this improvement so
after stressing
after about 2.48 we're obtained by using
um a method called the laser method
and more precisely the laser method was
introduced by strassen
so it's what i call the version one of
the analyzed by the laser method and
then
uh all the other um papers
the other um improvement successive
improvement were obtained by considering
more and more complicated tensors
so uh in particular the size of the
tensor increased
and in order to analyze it uh uh
more generalization of this analyze
based on
the laser method was needed so this was
laser method i would call it laser
method v2 for these
what's done by copper system rhinograd
and then b 2.1
2.2 2.3 and but
the point is that all the previous
versions or up to version 2.2
require to solve the complicated
optimization problem
which was very difficult uh when the
size of the tensor increased and with
the
this version 2.3 um
we can analyze the tensor in time of
polynomial in the size of the
tensor uh because the analysis is done
uh through convex optimization okay so
the main difference between
this version and the other version
and so uh our method can be described so
we can take if you take any tensor for
which you can obtain a
um an apartment on omega using as a
laser method
using our techniques so based on convex
optimization we can obtain the bound in
polynomial time
and the question is on which tensor we
want to to apply this well we don't have
many candidates
so what we will do we will apply the
this analysis on the powers of the basic
tensor from the paper by copper smith
and winograd
and so this bound
2.376 was obtained by considering the
second
power of the extensor by corpus missus
weinergrad
uh the improvement by storcer was over
cons
was obtained by considering the po were
four so the number
number variable in the optimization
problem increased nine
here and then virginia's result was
obtained by considering power 8
so 29 variables and
what we obtain is this very uh
slight improvement um by considering
power 16 and 32
and the number of variable is quite high
so we really need to our approach based
on convex optimization
to be able to obtain uh the numerical
bounds
corresponding to the other
okay so now uh i will uh go through
more details i will first start um uh
by uh explaining how to obtain lower
bonds
sorry upper bound so it's not lower bone
i don't know upper bounds on omega so it
has been done in the previous talk so
i will be very we'll do it very quickly
so um
so we have stress and algorithms which
show how to how to compute the product
of
two two by two matrices using only seven
multiplications
the point is that you can apply it
recursively and for
product of matrices of size two to the k
uh
you can do it with seven to the k
multiplication so this gives you this
bound
so this gives you uh one technique
which was called the the technique
number one the approach number one
in the previous talk and we see that if
you are able to show that you can
construct com compute the product of two
m by m matrices using t
multiplication then you obtain a bound
on
omega immediately using this formula and
so strassen algorithm is the case m
equal to and t equals seven and we will
see how it's uh
related to the rank in a few seconds
okay
so we will focus on we'll study the the
tensor of matrix multiplication the same
definition
as in the previous talks with the same
notation so bracket
m and p so this is a formal sum
but you can interpret it as a tensor so
an element
in the tensor product of three vector
spaces
um so well generally a
a tensor over uh
in an element of these vector spaces can
be written as the formal sum of this
form
if you consider a basis of the three
vector spaces
and the uh the definition i gave of the
tensor
of the matrix multiplication for the
case where the dimension of u is m
and dimension of these and p and
dimension w is mp
through this basis and these
coefficients
it's the same tensor as in the previous
steps
okay so now the rank so the rank uh
where i will use the r today not the
rank so the rank of this tensor
is of course author bounded by m n and p
and the strassen algorithm shows that
the rank of the tensor of
matrix multiplication of size two so two
by two matrices is at most seven
the point is that the rank represents
the number of multiplication of the best
uh
algorithm for the matrix product
and so we can rewrite uh what i
explained in a
few minutes ago uh by this inequality so
if you can show that the rank
of this matrix the tensor of this
measured product is smaller than t then
you obtain this inequality which gives
you
a bond on an upper bound anomaly and you
can generalize it
to as to rectangular matrices and you
can also generalize it you can replace
the rank by the border rank and since
the border
rank can be smaller than the rank this
gives you
a better bound in omega
okay and the third generalization is uh
the third approach in the previous talk
is the asymptotic sum inequality
so so if you can show that
an upper bound on the rank of a direct
sum of two
matrix products then you obtain
an inequality the involving omega and so
this gives you a way and
another way to obtain uh an optimum
omega and you can generalize it with a
direct sum of more than two terms
this is called the asymptotic sum
inequality and we will use it a lot in
this one
okay so um so
so the first two bonds here were
obtained by analysis of the ranks
the first uh the first technique the
this one by analyzes border rank and
this
bound by the asymptotic sum inequalities
and the last five bonds obtained by
a technique that i will not explain
which is the laser method okay
okay so i will first
work out the laser method on the simpler
example it's not very simple but it is
simpler that's the full
tensor by copper smith weiner brad so
first uh
why it's called laser method well i
don't really know the answer but uh well
stressing wrote a paper and where he
mentioned you give one possible
explanation of this term
so that it is reminiscent of the
generation of coherent light
this is the only uh
published explanation i have of the name
of a laser method
and so this reference was this
um this bounce so there's an 86
paper by strassen and all the further
improvement also use
variance or successive improvements of
this method
so i will not describe this the method
and then
the improvements okay so i will start
with what i said the simpler example
which is the first construction from the
paper by copper smith and white
grad which is a sum of three terms it
was pre it's
the same it was also presented in the
previous two
okay so um in this case we have
uh all the vector space our dimension q
plus one so we have
q plus one x variable q plus one y
variable and q plus one
z variable and as it's the sum of these
three terms
okay so this is a tensor isomorphic to
this matrix product
why because well you can uh
you can add the dummy uh by dummy index
000 and you see that this represents the
multiplication of a one one one by
one by one matrix by a one by two matrix
and you can do the same
for the other two the second is
isomorphic to this and the third is the
whole thing
so it's through parts as the through the
three terms represent
matrix products okay and the point is
that it's not a direct sum
because some variables are shared okay
here you have the same z
i variables here and here and the same x
x i variable here and here okay so
variables are shared so the sum of
the four the three terms is not
direct okay uh well you can
give a
more algebraic um description
of this decomposition into three terms
so you can consider the
uh this decomposition of youth is the
composition of v and w so you decompose
and use the row
u1 where you one correspond to variable
x1
and you use the root variable and you
want
to the other variables and you can see
that
this part is a tensor over u0 v1 and w1
so that's why we use the superscript
zero one one
and the same here and the same here
that's the same i mean the same
interpretation with this times these
levels one there one and one one zero
okay and this is not a direct sum
because the variable lies in the
in the same space here and here for
example
so it's not a direct sum so we cannot
use the asymptotic sum inequality
okay uh but the the the trick
to uh the essence of the laser method is
to consider
higher power of this tensor so for
example consider the power two
so the power 2 is the sum of
nine tips okay
so more generally you can consider for n
it will be the sum
of three to the three to the n sets
and uh so i should mention well i can
mention
uh it's really related to um
to uh to to the talk by chris so uh
here we will use the fact that the rank
of this
is upper bounded by n time
by q plus 2 to the n but if we are able
to
improve this upper bound by cube to q
plus 1 to the n plus something that it
will imply
omega is equal to two okay so this is
to to put a relation to a relation
between what i'm explaining here
and uh the conjecture uh in a chris uh
okay and um so we have three to the end
terms
and copper smith and weiner garage
showed how to select
among the three to the end terms this
number of terms that do not share
variable
and if they do not share variable this
will be a direct sum and we will be able
to obtain
an upper bound on omega using the
asymptotic
sum inequality okay
and by select i should be more precise
and
the point is that you can select it by
only zero zeroing variables
so this kind of selection will not
modify the ring will not increase the
rank
there's a crucial thing so this will be
a restriction of the initial tension
and the precise statement of uh um
this result by copper smith and weiner
groud is the following so this tensor
the nth power of tez can be converted so
again by zeroing
variables into a direct sum of this
number of terms
and each term containing
this number of copies of the first uh
path and this number of copy of the
second part and end over three copies of
the last part
okay here h represents the entropy
so if you do computation this
entropy is equal to this so you can
rewrite this them
as for those and uh so n copies of
each part rep is as a following meaning
so when you take
the nth power of t z you will obtain
three to the end terms
and yeah could you give some intuition
while the centerpiece shows up
uh
yes i will give it in a few minutes
okay yes if it yeah
uh yeah so yeah so we have a we have the
this number of terms and the first term
represents enco p of
the first part the last one and copy of
the last part and what we
the theorem is saying is that you can
select many terms and this term will not
be
of this type not of this type but
between between them balanced
the same number of copies of the first
the second and this
okay and uh so uh
a term isomorphic so containing this
number of copies is isomorphic to this
so
uh we know that it is isomorphic to this
matrix product
from the fact that each part here
is isomorphic to a matrix product
and um since then you can use the
asymptotic sum inequality
and uh so this gives you so this
we compute this let's give you this
so because we have here the stem here
and we know that
the m i n i p
i are all equal to q to the n over three
so you obtain this
inequality so know the rank of this is
at
the at most as a rank of t e z to the
power n
and which is uh q plus 2 to z
and then we do the numerical computation
so you
take power one over n and you do the
the optimization and you find that the
best value is q is equal to eight which
gives you an upper bound of two point
four zero threes
okay okay and i will try to give
an idea uh behind the proof
okay so uh i will
let's consider the case n equal to two
okay so we have nine tenths
so let's consider this step okay so what
is this term so you can compute it's uh
the tensor product of the first one and
the second one so this is equal to this
so
it's a tensor about over this
tensor in this vector space an element
of
this uh tensor space and if you look at
the surface the subscript so you have 0
1 1
0 1 1 here so we will label this stem
by uh this list of subscripts in this
order
okay so this one 0 1 1
0 one one and the other nines are also
levels
okay so we have nine levels
and so um let's consider the first
two here so we can write it as a label 0
1 1
0 1 1 and then explain here the label is
0 0 1 1 1 2. and
i said we want to extract terms we do
not
share variables from the sum of nine
tenths
and uh you see that these two these two
terms share variable you have the same
z i tensor the di prime
so we need to remove them and discard
the fact that the share variable can be
seen directly from the label we have the
same label here
one one and one the same green part of
those others
and we can remove this stem for example
by setting
all the variable in v1 tensor v1 to zero
okay so if you do this this will remove
this stem
because it has a variable in this
in this space but the point is that
this will remove this which is good for
us but it will also remove
other felts
okay so there are a lot of collateral
damage
in this technique you want to remove it
one time to avoid uh
to to make some dialect but if we try to
to do it this will
remove many of them so you have to do it
very carefully
okay so now we have this one so now we
can analyze say
let's say this one so there is no
conflict between the levels here so you
can keep it
but then there will be a conflict with
the other one so you will need to to
erase to remove this one and you can do
it
again by zeroing variable if you do it
for example by varying variables in this
space
okay so the conclusion is that you can
convert the second power
uh consisting initially of nine terms
into a direct sum
of two tenths and
uh you can do it only by uh by only
zeroing variables so the next step is to
consider power n
so in power n as i said there are three
to the n terms
and in this case uh each label will
consist of
binary strings of length three n so
three parts
and length is three n
and the theorem this theorem states
that um
we can obtain from this sum of three to
the n terms
this number of them so this number of
labels
that do not share a blue part a red part
of a green part and moreover the theorem
states that
the label will all have this form so the
blue part will consist
of n over three zeros two n over three
one
and the same for the red label and the
green level
and this is a very strong construct a
very powerful construction so it is here
that
the entropy appears is that um if you
look
at the number of possible strings
blue strings here under this condition
this number is given by
this combinatorial coefficient and this
combinatorial coefficient
is uh essentially this thing the entropy
the exponential of the entropy
okay and the theorem states that
actually yes you can saturate this
boundary
up to a minus zero one here negligible
term
so you can do the best you can
really almost saturate this start
it's a very strong theorem and it's uh
uh based on a quite complicated
construction using the existence of
dense sets of integer with no
three terms arithmetic progressions so
quite complicated and probabilistic
argument
of the existence of such a way of
converting
the sum into a direct sum
of this this number of
terms does it answer your question about
the entropy with your at least some
affiliate well
so yes i mean i think of
entropy is like this channel capacity
yes yes yes
and yes so there is no deep reason why
it is the entropies
via genius yesterday explained
everything using the combinatorial
coefficients
and the point is that community
coefficients can be expressed using the
entropy
yeah yeah there is no deep uh
yeah think about why that and i use
entropy
if it was simple entropy you didn't have
any of this
you know hard results like that simply
by entropy means that you have
certain let's say letters of let's have
of length six and yeah yeah and what are
combined but here you claim that this is
much more difficult
right this is based on some monstrous
arithmetic progression
so that's that's not a little lower one
is no it's because we're like have three
sources
so that's something but that's what it
is simply use this uh
this this equivalence
yeah so why do you need this this is the
point is that the entropy is concave
and this is a reason why we will be able
to do the conversion to to do the
optimization problem using
convex optimization but but uh the final
report fishes
are also context so
yes so you're just using that as well
yes we will use the fact that everything
will be complex yes
but i mean my number four fishes are
going to be
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah yeah of
course of course yeah
yeah you do it's not i mean it gives you
a simple way of
seeing that it is compact or concave yes
but of course we can do the same
analysis
without using the entropy yes it depends
so and now i will give the general
formulation of
the laser method and actually a
reinterpretation in term of entropy
and some kind of penalty terms so
to do this i need the notion of values
the value of a tensor it's exactly what
the
virginia explained the last uh yeah
yesterday so yesterday morning
so the definition of value is uh
motivated by
uh the asymptotic sum inequality so
um in order to use an obtained good bond
for the asymptotic
using the asymptotic sum inequality we
need to uh
to convert the tensor into a
a direct sum on many matrix
products and
the way of expressing the contribution
of the tensor to this
left term is expressed by the value so
technically so the value
uh for any row from
two to three and any n is a maximum
of this quantity over all restrictions
of the end power of the tensor
isomorphic to this
so you are considering always of
converting by
zeroing variable or even doing more a
general restriction
this tensor into something like that and
you take the
the way that maximize this quantity
and the value is considered as the
asymptotic
um value of this quantity so we are
taking
the power one over n of v or rho to the
n
and the limit exists and it's called the
value of two
well actually uh technically speaking
the definition only for symmetric tensor
if it's not symmetric we need to
symmetrize using
the cyclic shift of coordinates
and some properties or the value of
m and p the tensor product here is that
is m and p to the rho over three
okay and this is an increasing function
of rho
and it is a super additive and super
multiplicative
case of properties were discussed by uh
virginia yesterday
and so for example uh uh if you look at
the theorem by covalent rhinogloud so
they say that this
tensor can be converted in this number
of direct sum of this
number of terms it's isomorphic to this
so this simply shows that
the value with the n here of the t
e z is at least so this term multiply
by the value of this which is this okay
and if you take a power one over n
you obtain this uh this lower bound on
the right
and uh so um so the point is that
well with its notion of value you can
give the following uh
simple generic you can obtain the
following simple generalization of the
asymptotic thumb inequality that
the the value evaluated for uh
whole equal omega of t is smaller than
the border rank
it's not easy to it's not difficult to
generalize this inequality here
when you understand the notion this is
give you
a conscious way of expressing the
asymptotic sum
okay so uh now uh i need another
generalization the decomposition of uh
of a tensor so uh again a tensor
is an element in this space in the the
tensor product of three vector space
so if you assume that the three vector
space u v and w
are decomposed as direct sums
of that space then
we say that the tensor t the partition
tensor with respect to this precise
decomposition
if it can be written in this way so as a
sum of t
i j k where each t i j k
is a tensor in u i
tensor v j tensor w
so it's a partition tensor if the tensor
can be partitioned with respect
to this the conversation
okay and the support will be well i
usually
all the triple u j k such that the t
i j k is not a zero tensor
and each nonzero t tij we will call a
component
of t and we say that the tensor is tight
if for any for any triple
of this in the support you have i plus j
plus k equal to d
where d is some constant it's a field
yeah what what's a texture that's not
partitioned
yeah so yes so any tensor it's
particularly the trivial
yes yeah yeah yes yes so
the point here is to fix the the
composition you ask is you can
partition it according with respect to
this decomposition
okay yes but you're right so any tensor
is a trivial zero trigger
so tight depends on the partition yes
yes to fix your partition
so for example here while we add all the
composition here
we use u0 u1 v0 v1 0 w 1
and this corresponds to the case where
we have two elements the partition here
and we have three components so the
support is
this this slip term consists of these
three terms and it's tight because if
you take the sum is equal to two
so it's an example of uh partition
tensor with respect to this part
and now here the main theorem of this
talk which is actually a
reinterpretation of
all prior works with different notations
and to makes explicit that we have
concave
parts in this expression so say that
for any title we need really really that
the tensor is tight but for any tight
partition tensor
so when you fix the partitions and any
probability distribution over the
support
and in your row you have this inequality
so let's give you a lower bound on the
value
okay and here h is the entropy pl
is a projection of p along the else
coordinate
so these are marginal distributions
there are three marginal distributions
because there are three coordinates
and gamma p is attempt to be defined
later
so in the next five minutes gamma p will
be equal to zero
zero for the simple cases it's become a
non-zero only for
high power of the copper smithsonian
operator
so i don't see
anything in here i mean you have row on
both sides
yes yes
i guess we'll see how this gets
exploited but yeah are you asking how
we get the lower bounds and that is how
you exploit this anymore so we will
exploit it by assuming that we know
the values of these components
and then we know this value so that we
use it so the first part is something
coming to pearl like a number of
different ways
selecting something exactly and then the
second is since it's going to be
exponentially
it's the second term that is is the cost
of each component and then there's some
correction term at the end
exactly exactly but you really want the
value on the left hand side you don't
have a border right there
and so we will use the border rank there
after that
to obtain the bound on uh okay
so yes it's precisely this so the point
is that we can compute the lower bound
on the value of t
if we know a lower bound on the value of
each component so if we know these
things
and then if we use this expression
then you can obtain an overall bound on
only and more precisely what we will do
we will use this this implication
and we will do a binary research on the
whole
what is a simple tensor you say simple
is a
simple it's no mathematical definition
here it's an easy tensor
so if it is small very small dancer uh
it's usually their role
without the gum quality it looks very
familiar to me
yeah yes it's yes in your book yeah
yeah so yeah the point is that even if
the components are not matrix
multiplication
and even if uh so if
each tij is isomorphic to matrix
multiplication you don't have any
penalty term
and when it's not then you have a
penalty term so it's the main
strength yes i would have explained it
yes so for example here well
as a support is this again and
uh so the probability distribution when
you can take
the symmetric one so one third for each
of the three terms
and well actually for this i didn't
define what it is as a stem
penalty term but in for this case it
will be zero
you can compute the marginal
distribution so p1
0 which is one third p11 which is the
sum
of these two things so two thirds and
the same for the two other marginal
distributions
and this gives you this bond
okay and well if you remember what we
had here well it's the same bond
here easy to say the same thing and it's
not a coincidence because there is a one
one correspondence between
all terms so these terms represent the
number here
and the number of copies n over three is
one third
and uh this term is in correspondence
here so this is the value
of this so we have a one one
correspondence
and more generally so the interpretation
of this formula and the way
it is proved is that the laser method
enable us to convert
by the ring variable the ends power of t
into a direct sum of this number of
terms
each isomorphic to do this
okay so this is the the interpretation
of
this formula and the weights it's probed
by generalizing the argument by
congratulations
okay and so now we have a formula so we
can apply it on
uh many uh any type of tensor
so we can apply it on the copper
smithsonian tensor so with this
which was uh described in many talks
especially the previous one so it's a
sum of six stems it's obtained by
using the previous one and adding three
terms here
and so we have your six terms so this
corresponds to this decomposition the
composition u v and w and this time in
three parts and
again it's not the direct sum um
so the support in this case would be as
before but with these three additional
elements so we know
the value of uh each component
and what we'll do you can take this
distribution
okay with y well we can can take any
distribution so we can take a
symmetric distribution so value alpha
for the three values here and the
remaining will be
very one over three minus half
alpha for any alpha between zero one
third and
you can compute the marginal
distribution and then you apply the crm
and this gives you this bound
okay and if you do the optimization you
find that this gives you this
okay so after that it's quite mechanical
and this gave you this
and so the second power well it's a 36
stem and you can rewrite it as a sum of
50 them
as virginia explained yesterday using
some merging
and then
what you have you have a 15 10 so the
support will be
of this form then you can compute lower
bounds on the value of each component
for these three
components it's easy because they are
isomorphic to matrix multiplication
for the fourth one it's more complicated
because it's not isomorphic to matrix
multiplication tensor but you can
compute the value recursively okay
and then while you choose your
distributions and we will have
four parameters you if you well
you can try to to take the uh symmetric
uh distribution it turns out to be the
the optimal uh a good choice the optimal
optimal
distribution is symmetric in this case
so we have
four parameters and so means the sum
should be one so actually three
parameters
and again you have gamma equal to zero
so
uh if you do the numerical optimization
this gives you this above
so it's really mechanical and so what
about the start power well
doesn't give any improvement but the
fourth power will give it
so the first power this time was this
number of terms and
you are regrouping you deserve merging
you will have
you will have this time only nine
parameters
okay so 10 family of components
so nine parameters but this time gamma
is not equal to zero
so i should now explain what is gamma
so gamma is the max of
this quantity minus this
so it's a max of the of the entropy
over all distribution the max of the
entropy of q where
the max over q all the distribution q
which are the same marginal distribution
as
p okay
and when the structure of the sim
support is simple this will be zero but
in general it's not zero the fourth
for the fourth power it's not zero so
just
can you give a simple example
well i know can you give an example
where these things are not
uh i won't give an example there is no
very simple example
i can give you
an interpretation on why there is a
penalty term that would be great
yes so the point is that so the
interpretation is that the laser method
enables us to convert the t to the n
into a direct sum of terms it's
isomorphic to something like that
so p i will say that a term of this form
is a
of type p okay and what we want to do
is to uh to control p
we want to to to contract p and choose p
p such that uh
the value is uh optimal but you cannot
do it because you are
you can only zero variables
okay so this means that you can only
control the marginal distribution p1 p2
and p3 p1 correspond shooting p1
correspond to
chewing choosing which x variable you
want to
to zero okay so you can only control
the marginal distribution so what you
obtain is a
non-direct sum of all type q temps
okay a q satisfying this condition
and the most frequent ends are those
with q maximizing the
the the entropy so when
when when keeping only those of type of
p
you will have a penalty term which is
large if
the uh the the term of type p are not
the most frequent
okay so that's why uh we have this um
so we want to optimize this so what's
the
disadvantage of taking your distribution
to be the cue the the one that maximizes
where does it cost you
somewhere you're taking a queue sorry
you're thinking
just go back so yeah so we have you have
a queue
yes yeah um why don't you just take
q instead of p and then your gamma p
goes to zero where
you pay so you must pay because it may
not be
optimal for this term for uh this stem
let's see so a lower value yes yes
yes you're right since we have we don't
have any
penalty we have the same here because
it's the same marginal distribution but
we may have something smaller here
so you can take q and that gamma will be
zero but it may give a lower
exactly yeah you can take q and actually
yes so it's what is done in uh
some sort of prior work so so
uh so the point is that well if there is
no penalty then
everything is uh is easy because it's a
maximization of a concave function
under linear constraints so is this your
main contribution this
gamma p term then i mean yes it's really
formalizing this
uh showing that you have a penalty term
which is actually concave and
use something that's non-optimal for the
penalty that optimizes value more yes
and then it's showing how to convert
this into a convex optimization problem
yeah so if there is no penalty term it's
not
uh it's not difficult
because this is concave the entropy is
concave this is linear
when this term is fixed and the only
condition is that these are probability
distributions those linear constraints
and when it is not uh zero
what's the very nasty optimization
problem this can be done actually
or up to the fourth power it's a very
complicated program but this can be done
for the source for words has been done
by saucers giving this
and otherwise it's extremely complicated
so what virginia did is she restricted
the search the set of distribution p
such that gamma p is equal to zero but
it's a
it's not a convex set it's a very
difficult structure this set
so uh the optimization is still very
hard very difficult but while this can
be done
for the up to the eighth ball
and after that it's much more
complicated
so what we do here
we we find we propose a method to find a
solution this is not the optimal
solution but it will be close to the
optimal solution i mean numerically
apparently this is very close to the
optimal solution and the way of doing
this
is to first find a distribution p that
maximize
this expression without this term
without the penalty term
and then to find
a distribution that maximize
hq under the constraint that q should
have the same marginal
as the solution of the first problem and
then output
fq okay the point is that the first
problem is a concave of the objective
function and linear constraint so it's
easy to do
the second the same so concave objective
function linear constraints are also
very easy to do
and uh since gamma q hat is equal to
zero we know that
the output will be a lower bound on the
on the log of the value so what other
constraints you have in the second step
the constraint is that the marginal
distribution of q are the same as the
marginal distribution of p
p we have the product of the margins
sorry it's just the product of the
marginals i mean the one that maximizes
the entropy for the product it's a we
have q1 equal
p1 hot and the same for the other two
all right i'm saying the one that
maximizes the entropy isn't just the
product
of the marginals i want to maximize the
entropy of q
of the distribution and the condition is
that
the marginal distribution of q should be
equal to the marginal distribution
of the distribution we have found at the
previous step
yes i'm saying isn't the maximizing cube
just a product of the margins
maximizing q as a product of margin
the coordinates aren't independent it's
a simplex rather than a cube basically
i see you have a different
okay what's a linear constraint
and this gives you an upper bound and
numerically very close to zero it seems
to be very close to the optimal solution
and we obtain this
this bounds by and you can use convex
optimization
okay and finally the final slide
so what we have done we have constructed
what we call the time efficient
implementation of the laser method so if
you have any tight partition tensor for
which you know lower bound the value of
each component
and for which you know an
upper bound on the rank then in
polynomial time with inconvex
optimization you can obtain an upper
bound
and we used it on the powers of the
basic
tensor by copper smith and winograd and
well so recent result
we have shown that actually um
if you use the same approach and study
higher powers
then as cannot give an upper bound
better than 2.3725
so it's almost game over for that uh
very victims
and that precise approach okay so thank
you
questions the same approach means
merging the cells or yes so the same
so the same approach means that we are
taking only powers of two
and we are doing exactly the same
merging exactly yes
and we have another bound for any
merging
and any power not not a power of two
and the lower bound is two point three
zero seven
eight and do you also have a bounce for
any decomposition
yes it's for uh
no it's not for any decomposition you
fix the
composition of the first power into
three parts
and then you can have any emerging and
any decomposition is emerging
yes only fix the first power and you
have a lower
2.3 or something yes so
why do you use this coppersmith vinegar
tensor i mean what's
special about it to you
so do you have a bedroom
well yes
i mean yeah nowhere well
yes it's let's give that the best
balances only i
can try to modify it a little bit other
things but it doesn't give
something better i haven't found any
update
but i don't have any let me praise the
question in a a different way okay it's
given good results
but is it there anything that when you
look at it you say
ah this one should give me good results
or is it only just based on
previous experience i don't have
an interpretation why this gives a good
risk
good results it's symmetric which is a
nice thing
but no i don't have a
such intuition about what's a good
answer and but
then self-worth
that's that's only because we can
compute if the border rank is an
arranged we can compute it
that's what makes it so we know it's we
know it's cost exactly
i agree okay listen